un changement de calendrier.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les Paulareds sont presque
toutes récoltées au Domaine de
Dunham et elles ont rempli le
quart des caisses seulement.
- Normalement, si on ne tient
pas compte des arbres qu'on a
coupés, on en aurait fait 80.
Et puis voyez-vous,
cette année, on en a 21.
- Avec le gel du printemps,
de nombreux bourgeons sont morts
ou ont donné des fruits
difformes. Puis, la chaleur
s'est installée plus tôt
et dure plus longtemps
que d'habitude.
CLAUDE GIRARD, copropriétaire du
Domaine de Dunham
- La chaleur est intense, ça ne
fait pas rougir les fruits.
C'est le froid qui fait rougir
les fruits. Mais les fruits
continuent à mûrir quand même.
Alors ce qui se passe,
c'est qu'à un moment donné,
le fruit a atteint sa maturité
pour l'entreposage,
mais il n'a pas la couleur,
donc il va être rejeté au tri.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les vergers doivent aussi
composer avec le manque de
pluie, qu'ils ne peuvent plus
compenser par l'irrigation.
- Normalement, l'eau part d'ici
et c'est à égalité l'autre côté.
C'est un des deux bassins
d'irrigation qu'on a.
Ça contient quand même
habituellement une très,
très grande quantité d'eau parce
que le centre est très creux.
- La chaleur et le temps sec
se font particulièrement sentir
à Dunham à cause du micro-climat
mais la saison s'annonce réduite
aussi dans les autres vergers.
- On parle d'environ une baisse
de 8 %, c'est-tu 5, c'est-tu 10,
par rapport à notre moyenne
5 ans. C'est pas dramatique.
- La clé de la saison,
ce sera la McIntosh, la variété
la plus cultivée au Québec.
STÉPHANIE LEVASSEUR, présidente
Producteurs de pommes du Québec
- Il faut qu'il fasse froid
la nuit, puis soleil le jour
pour que la pomme prenne son
rouge. Pour l'instant, il nous
reste encore une semaine ou deux
avant de s'inquiéter vraiment.
- Mais dans tous les cas,
les pommes seront prêtes plus
tôt, ce qui est compliqué parce
que les travailleurs étrangers
ne sont souvent pas encore
disponibles et les visiteurs
n'ont pas encore la tête
aux pommes.
GISÈLE LAROCQUE, copropriétaire
du Domaine de Dunham
- Cette année, c'est très lent
parce qu'il fait trop chaud.
Les gens sortent pas,
ils sont à la piscine.
Normalement, ils viendraient
aux pommes.
- Mais c'est plus tôt en plus.
- C'est beaucoup,
deux semaines plus tôt.
Si on peut avoir des belles
journées fraîches, ensoleillées,
15 degrés, là il y a foule.
- Les arbres devraient
quand même être bien chargés
pour les autocueilleurs,
à condition qu'ils devancent
un peu leur sortie cette année.
Ici Marie-Claude Morin,
Radio-Canada, à Dunham.